no puedo mostrarles las caras de todo
pero hay arquitectos ingenieros
estudiantes hasta un Joyero que tiene
una galería y vino hasta acá para qué
para llenar bolsas de tierra y construir
estos puntos
que se moviliza para defenderse
construyendo un puesto de control porque
aquí todo el mundo piensa que la guerra
se seguirá propagando por Ucrania que
llegará hasta estos lugares del oeste
del país estamos a 500 km de kievs pero
aquí también todo se preparan para la
guerra estos hombres y mujeres se
movilizaron a pesar del frío extremo
todos dejaron sus trabajos y sus
familias para movilizarse y venir a
fabricar esos artefactos defensivos para
la
ciudadran hasta el final que nadie
piensa irse aquí se van a quedar para
defender la patria ucraniana Y abatir a
quién llaman el tirano Putin hay un
enorme espíritu de movilización y de
comunidad